nearly all republicans in the u.s senate
have made it clear they are not ready to
convict former president trump in his
impeachment trial
all 100 senators were sworn in as jurors
yesterday and then
one republican tried to stop it soon
afterward the democrat who will preside
over the trial that senator patrick
leahy
was taken to a hospital nicole killian
is on capitol hill nicole how is he
doing
vlad senator patrick leahy is home and
could be back on the job as early as
today his spokesperson says he wasn't
feeling well in his office
yesterday and was taken to the hospital
out of an abundance of caution
all senators now rise and raise their
right hand
not long after administering the oath to
his fellow senators in former president
trump's impeachment trial
vermont senator patrick leahy was
transported to this washington d.c
hospital for observation
kentucky senator rand paul tried to have
the proceedings dismissed
on constitutional grounds democrats are
wasting the nation's time
on a partisan vendetta against a man no
longer in office
only five republicans joined democrats
to defeat the motion
signaling an uphill battle since
democrats will need
17 republicans to convict the former
president
mr trump will be represented by south
carolina attorney butch bowers
in his first interview with the
washington post bowers would not say if
the former president will appear at the
trial
or if he will call witnesses he told the
paper
you'll see our case when we present it
and i think the facts
and the law will speak for themselves
three weeks after the right that led to
mr trump's impeachment
acting capital police chief yogananda
pittman apologized to lawmakers in a
closed door session
she said the department knew militia
groups and white supremacists would
attend
and may have weapons acknowledging the
department failed
and should have been more prepared for
this attack we
knew at some level they knew but the
real question
is you know why was that intelligence
not acted upon
federal investigators have opened up
cases into more than 400 potential
suspects and expect to bring
sedition charges against some of them
soon tony
nicole thank you very much